at the disused factory they bide their
time over 2,000 of them desperate to get
into Europe for either asylum or work
but Hamid is going to have to wait a bit
longer
before breaking cover again the Croatian
police broke his arm in three places a
few days ago if they deported you and in
the daytime you know they don't beat you
that much but if it's the night shift
you know they beat you as much as they
can and do a lot of people in here do
they all say the same thing yes some of
them got beaten some of them not beaten
you know it depends on how many times
you try game we call it a game I don't
know if you know it if you lose it you
come back again here it's good to get
into the European Union from Bosnia
means crossing the mountains and the
game involves dodging the Croatian
police they are now widely accused of
brutal assaults routine theft of money
and phones occasionally shooting
migrants a group of officers raised the
stakes recently writing a joint
anonymous letter admitting it and
claiming they were being told to do it
they are using illegal ways of
communicating like true what's up or
viber or through private phones so none
of this is being yes so nothing is
controlled and nobody knows what the
content of these exchanges were then
they use civil clothes they use civil
cars journalists have also accused the
Croatians of attacking them so he got
the Bosnians to escort us up the track
the migrants take this is also the
external border of the European Union
Croatia was just became presidents of
the EU wants to join the free movement
Schengen zone that means signing up to
fortress Europe last year nearly 50,000
people left Bosnia and into the European
Union here illegally and once they're
done so Croatia were
faul happiest let them carry on to italy
or wherever than here their asylum
claims in that sense many people think
that Croatia's tough-guy act towards the
refugees and migrants is really a game
of its own designed to prove to the
European Union how good it is its
security over the last few days the
Great and the good from the European
Union have been in Croatia and the Prime
Minister has spent every news conference
stressing how committed his country is
to border enforcement
he always glosses over questions about
police brutality from a legal
perspective violence at the borders is
never acceptable it's acceptable - it's
illegal isn't it's illegal yes and it is
is of course acceptable for a country to
protect its borders and to monitor and
to prevent people from coming in in
accordance with international standards
but it is not acceptable to use values
the apparent tolerance of police
violence towards asylum seekers here is
the starkest illustration of how the EU
now regards security as the only game in
town migration flows and not what they
were a few years ago but Nora Human
Rights Laurence Lee al-jazeera
on the Croatian border